well Donald Trump has announced dominate
the streets with compassion with
compassion the best compassion everyone
agrees Donald Trump says he will unveil
it I was good right he will look at that
s he will unveil an executive order on
police reform to dominate the streets
with compassion at Dallas round table oh
but but but he didn't invite city's
black top law enforcement officials oh
no what does that mean too dumb what do
you say okay he says in his first
remarks in police reform he describes
his response to the protests as
dominating but with compassion we are
doing it with compassion if you think
about it we are dominating the street
with compassion just head over and over
did you imagine a bunch of light you
know like just a bunch of cops walking
down through the protest giving out
flowers and stuff with in hugs yeah
peace be with you be with you be with
you know I'm I don't know what that's
supposed to mean I do and I find it to
be quite silly but it's quite trumpian
because you know he wanted he had before
we need to dominate and then everyone
got mad now you know what Trump needs to
own it he does because because he does
own it though doesn't he well I mean
saying dominate with compassion it's
like it's no Trump you're right that's
very trumpian it is like what you're
gonna the cops are gonna be smiling when
they fire their rubber bullets at you
[Laughter]
yep they're gonna be saying like I love
you there and you know so what they do
is they'll get their sticks and they'll
jump for it same time ago move maybe
they'll put flowers in the barrels of
the gun no no the instead instead of
yelling blow rubber bullets but move as
they as they jab you what they're to go
I love you respect I care about you
you're valued you're gonna be hitting
people and trampling them and then the
tear gas is going to have like hearts on
it the only thing you should be doing
that too is the like button that's right
smash that like button so I don't I
don't know if they actually talk about
what Trump's real plan is gonna be ways
is the roundtable included
african-american leaders from the fields
of religion law enforcement and small
sona's then why do they title it saying
he didn't invite them yeah so done I'm
sorry what
in recent days President Trump
repeatedly stated his support for police
and said progress would not be made by
calling millions of Americans racists
that he is right about in recent days
there have been vigorous discussions
about how to ensure fairness equality
and justice for all our people
unfortunately there's something there's
some trying to stoke the division and to
push an extreme agenda which we won't go
for that will probably produce only more
poverty more crime more suffering this
includes radical efforts to defund
dismantle in disband the police he added
the solid solid points right there right
good I exactly like it is very clear
that they want to keep a division and
divide us all instead of just saying
we're all Americans we're all in this
together let's figure it out together
well they were all about being in it
together up until they decided they
needed to protest right and then we were
all separate think about every you think
about this every single commercial from
these corporations where it did the same
exact thing where he chose like a little
kid you know laughing and then it shows
like cell phone footage and then it goes
to video lumens to guru and everyone got
really annoyed with it like and then as
soon as the protests started they
immediately run full-speed to say we're
with this we're with you here here not
you though you stay in your house yeah
but we're in this together now they're
now kovetz coming back of course it is
do the craziest thing about it is that
when Vox wrote the Vox like on the
left-wing site wrote that kovin was
spiking in Arizona they were like we
can't seem to figure out why these
spikes are happening perhaps it's
because they reopened the economy on May
15th it's like a month ago dude or
thousands of people gathered over the
past two weeks or maybe five days ago
you guys were all like let's go party in
the streets and do the electric shuffle
or whatever Electric Slide oh yeah that
thing the videos of the cops doin like
the dance with the people and it's like
and now they're getting sick and they've
all they all seem to have amnesia just
woke up one day completely forgot they
were cheering for and advocating
everyone going out and doing these
things so do us yeah yeah I wonder if
the American people can see it yeah so
apparently there was a story about
I briefly saw this I don't know the full
details but one American News did a poll
in Florida and found that is actually
tied with you know Trump and Biden are
tied oh really
yeah and there was they were surprised
to see it and that to me is is shocking
who did they ask I'm always curious
polls I don't know the numbers vary so
much I see polls all the time but here
today I saw thirty nine percent to like
you know I don't know it was like fifty
five or something Abidin but any I need
any doubt that we would be wrong is
completely removed once you see the
double standard when it comes to them
cheering for the black lives matter
protesters and condemning the anti
lockdown protesters right now they're
pretending like they don't know what's
causing this Bill DeBlasio was asked
they saw like of spike in cases and he
goes we can't figure out why this is
happening
what you just celebrated the protesters
you were just on TV talking about your
daughter getting arrested you know and
you forgot I gotta tell you man if if
Joe Biden wins and the Democrats
continue this my only assumption is that
you have two factions in this country
morons who can't read and people who can
yeah cuz at a certain point you can hate
Donald Trump but well actually you know
I can't imagine anybody is going to look
at how the media is functioning how
they're lying to you bout everything and
then think I would like to support that
but I guess hey maybe when you're so
blinded with rage for you know Donald
Trump you don't have a functioning brain
like you're just your trump derangement
syndrome makes you go insane yeah maybe
and then they're just yeah okay honestly
it felt like the Democrats were totally
okay with everyone that was out marching
to get kovat it's like they were like
yeah no no everyone stay inside but if
you're if you're for black lives matter
go go March and it's like did are we you
were shoving it down our throat that
this virus was so scary that it's so
infectious ever it's novel everyone's
gonna get it and then all of a sudden
you're like no no go out there and
protest for your right to protest but
only if that's your cause everyone else
stay inside it's like what now there's a
spike and now they're like
what happened we don't know sorry
everybody
it looks like you're gonna get a lot of
more deaths all those Fred's dance what
yeah and then it's not red states it's
blue cities blue states that are gonna
tell all these new deaths from great
well then there are there are blue
cities in these red states okay but like
what caused the spike in Miami and it's
like there is a major protest yeah in
Miami all right I mean what hello
science yeah but dude I have to imagine
there are a lot of people who are really
really dumb and I see them posting on
Facebook and I think I think you know a
lot of people underestimate just how
dumb they are yeah so like I see some
people that I know from you know Chicago
and they'll post things where it's like
they clearly just saw one article one
time and that was that's the extent to
which they understand politics yeah and
it'll be a lot you know Donald Trump
like you know I don't know punches puppy
or something and then they'll be like
our and then we try and talk to them
they're gonna be alike I have no idea
you're talking about so they really just
are disengaged you know though I I do
think though I'm seeing it too the riots
activated a ton of people a ton a ton of
people in which which way they're both
both way and I don't know which ones
more or less but I can't tell you yeah
there was this researcher who was
apparently like a bernie supporting like
social democrat or something I don't
know political affiliation but he's
supposed to supposedly a lefty okay he
tweeted out this study that found
following the assassination of MLK there
were riots and that swung the vote two
points towards Republicans which gave
Nixon the win
Wow and they've actually now tracked the
data showing that peaceful protests give
Democrats an advantage because it
bolsters high-level elite talking points
and news media and riots give
Republicans an advantage because it
triggers fear and anxiety and same thing
the media yeah so when you look at these
big peaceful protests the press starts
talking about this cause and the
celebrations and then Democrats here
then they go but then you replace that
with explosions and chaos and screaming
and warlords and regular Americans see
that and they go so who do you think's
gonna keep you safe Trump or Joe Biden
I'd like if you that that giggle was the
thought of
trying to take the American public safe
is the analogy that I often give is like
you're in a schoolyard and you're told
to vote for which person is gonna
protect you from the bullies or whatever
and you can choose Joe Biden who's
asleep in his chair snoring in the
corner or Donald Trump who is literally
the bully pushing people around yeah you
know be like if I vote for you will you
be the guy I'll stand in front of you
don't worry I'm the best I'll push
everybody out of your way you're like
I'm front of the line for the ice cream
the best ice cream yes yep excuse me
excuse me
chocolate for my friend here two scoops
my friend thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. if you want to catch the full
show tune into this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you